tout nouveau téléphone de la marque
uniforme marque chinoise qui est
intéressant pourquoi sur deux points et
bien le premier c'est que vous avez une
caméra implémentée sous l'écran ça c'est
plutôt bien ça fait disparaître les
caméras de selfie qu'on aime pas trop
voir forcément donc ça c'est plutôt cool
c'est le premier point qui est
intéressant et puis le deuxième point
qui est extrêmement intéressant c'est
que vous avez comme sur les iPhone
l'appel satellite d'urgence vous êtes
dans un endroit vous ne captez pas vous
n'avez pas de réseau et bien vous allez
pouvoir contacter directement les
secours grâce à l'appel satellite alors
ça un smartphone qui arrivera un peu
plus tard qui est pour l'instant et plus
le prototype pour bien voir ici il
arrivera probablement dans la deuxième
partie de l'année c'est le Armor 23
ultra puis les fan c'est une marque
qu'on retrouve beaucoup et notamment sur
le marché chinois elle est intéressante
parce qu'elle cherche toujours à propos
de nouvelles technologies à des tarifs
plutôt de maîtriser plutôt canon c'est
pas forcément une fois de plus les
produits qu'on va venir acheter nous
prendre un petit peu le bout de la tech
de voir quelle direction elle vient
prendre et puis surtout ce qu'on voit
parce que très cool c'est que le sujet
de la caméra sous l'écran est vraiment
omniprésent et c'est un sujet qui va
être de plus en plus intéressant les
appels d'urgence à côté très rassurant
pour tous les gens qui font de la route
d'or les gens qui vont dans la montagne
est-ce que une de ces deux
fonctionnalités phares de ce smartphone
pourrait vous intéresser marquez moi ça
bien évidemment dans les commentaires